this guy's gonna be another washed-up
pencil pusher it's only concerned with
following every rule and the patrol
guide meet more robot captain engage is
that what you think
hey new captain alert you must be the
new CEO I'm detective Jake Peralta great
to meet you no don't let me interrupt
you we're describing what kind of person
I'm gonna be I'd like you to finish it's
not necessary
or I could recap very quickly sure um
let's see I think I said some joke about
a washed-up pencil pusher now did the
robot voice the robot voice you were
doing when you were implied I'm a
rule-following robot I want to hear it
again sir robot that's a terrible robot
voice yep the next time I see you I'd
like you to be wearing a necktie Oh
actually the last captain didn't care if
we wore ties well your new captain does
and more importantly he cares that you
follow his direct orders everyone I'm
your new commanding officer captain ray
Holt speech that was my speech short
sweet captain Hall to eating a
marshmallow for the very first time what
is this glutinous monstrosity before me
sugar and this is quite sweet that's
your Holt impression I can hear him
doing that looks like a sticky pillow I
don't care for it
classical music what's going on here
what are you doing
captain Hey nothing just eating some
marshmallows care for one more stir Milo
I know it are you trying to monkey haul
me it's unbelievable
I don't need Monty Hall ruining my place
of work with Monty Hall has already
ruined my home life well sir the math
thing isn't the problem night shifts
keeping you and Kevin apart you two just
need a bone
I said you two need a bone
Oh dare you detective Diaz I am your
superior officer Oh what happens in my
bedroom detective is none of your
business
don't ever speak to me like that again
why'd she choose that dude his pen up
now he knows
problem solved Oh captain I know you
don't want to talk about Monty Hall but
I did contact a mattress no need
Santiago it's all good so fight with
Kevin is over yep because you understand
the math nope hey guys you guys yep
knew it see what happen is your dad's
had sex okay Rosa attention everyone I
can hear you speculating about the
nature and origin of my injury from my
office I tripped over an uneven sidewalk
I did not think it was relevant to your
jobs the jobs which you should all be
doing right now get to work
do you want to know how I actually hurt
my wrist yes I was looking Kevin and I
attend a class for fitness and for fun
oh my god I've mastered all the moves
the pizza toss the tornado the Scorpion
the oopsie doodle why are you telling
this because no one will ever believe
you no no
sick son of a [ __ ] I'm happy our Drug
Task Force was a success and today I get
to watch my nemesis madeline wuntch
drape a medal around my neck also we
clean up the streets yeah sure that's
good too so I've been planning how to
zing Madeline when she puts the medal on
I have the perfect line once time is
over so it's a play on lunchtime
yes devastating burns sir but you know
what would really show her is if you
said nothing at all Oh interesting
interesting let let Madeline know she's
not even worth my staying up all night
crafting zingers lunchtime took you all
night
trust me turn the other cheek which I
recently learned is about faces and not
butts but works either way yes I should
be the bigger person
shouldn't be hard given that methods not
technically a prison for meritorious
service the NYPD bestows this award on
detective Rosa Diaz Jake Peralta and
captain Raymond Holt
Raymond Madeline you one go ahead and
gloat you toad thank you for this honor
deputy chief no okay you're welcome
once time is over boom no regrets twelve
are you eating an Italian sub for
breakfast I am but Amy said I should eat
more veggies so I got extra pepper
tunics smart Chuy you need to watch
yourself
I'm sorry cop alright let's everybody
just stay calm here
Oh what are you gonna arrest me for
dancing you call that dancing
this is dancing what is happening I'm
just using the situation
[Applause]
Coenen butter from making butter come on
it here we go dancing over situation
confused it's a great picture sir I
hated meet you so I have an eyewitness
in the purse-snatcher case only problem
is the sketch artist is out sick how do
you want me to proceed figure it out
Santiago it's your case yes I will do
that thank you
are you bowing no this is how I walk
what do you need Quasimodo I gotta go
meet Boyle and Peralta there's something
wrong with the captain it seems like
he's in a bad mood I don't know who
could tell you're a captain tough
weekend I went to Barbados with my
husband
we won't hats out of palm fronds and
swam with the stingrays I've never been
happier hey sergeant you know you're
really good at UM doodling I know you
think you're complimenting me but
calling them doodles is an insult you
big fan of Picasso's doodles sorry can
you please drop her for me the sketch
artist is out sick and the captain wants
us done right away he's in a bad mood is
it like I never read on chipper captain
you have a fun weekend
there was a small fire in my home I lost
many photo albums of treasured memories
I'm devastated their problem uh yeah you
know how I've been defying all
expectations by going back to school I
always knew yeah I didn't you can't you
just be blown away by me I need someone
to take this personality test for my
psych class I was hoping that while my
professor with a genuine psycho like Amy
or Hitchcock or Charles would be great
I'm not a psycho but I could take your
test that would be awesome
I do need to warn you that the results
can be well unflattering it's okay I'm
no stranger to unflattering test results
your blood pressure's normal normal
take it again I'm not afraid to have my
flaws exposed just to be clear though it
is possible to get a result that shows
no flaws I guess good good
can't wait to begin
yes um I just wanted to thank you for
all your help yesterday I didn't do much
there was nothing good day
what's going on just very busy get back
to work what are you having they're a
little larger oh my god captain she is
magnificent vindication Thiago was
officially late for the first time ever
all right let's do this who's got
theories alarm didn't go up all three
alarms all with battery backup come on
who wants to take this seriously
oh she was taken in her sleep that's
what I'm talking about
super dark foil but way more plausible
than the Sarge's idiotic alarm clock
theory I bet she tucked herself into bed
too tight and got stuck maybe she fell
into another dimension where she's
interesting it's 9:00 a.m. why is no one
working Amy Santiago is a few minutes
late and we're all trying to guess why I
like to play I'd say she's in line at
the bank this is fun it is fun but
you're all wrong she clearly slipped
through a subway grate and is having
terrible sex with a mole man there she
is Amy where have you been we've been
worried sick do you care to explain
yourself I'm just 70 seconds late it's
not a big deal don't worry about it
Santiago you will tell us and you will
tell us now there's a problem at the
bank
you